do something cool all right
this is my recap for my class bouncing
through geometry Justin Hindi
crystals wraps bicep raps
stationary positions vaccine from bottom
to top
and also your grip
because some people hold them at the
bottom
but you want them to be for depending on
how long your pulley are actually if you
got Short play they might work just fine
at the handles like that but with my
Long Point
because
it's way better
and also you can tweak your hand
to where you want it to wrap your arm
so once we got wraps also legs
both sides
floppy pants don't work too great
um once we went through those wraps we
started going through
what I like to call through wraps
one arm
three wrap is essentially wrapping
through Iran
told you guys to practice
both sides both directions
opposite arms
midnight went through how you can do
the
split opposite two wraps on the same arm
the wall plane
or you can do it on opposite arms
practice healer
and then
I win um over
instead of through wraps
it's like bouncing into your arms
so if you're in your stationary position
you bounce in and you can choose kind of
where you want to go through this
sounds horizontal
vertical
save patterns from those Direction
changing bounces
so
I went over
this pattern
and also
to help with the technique of that
pattern
if your hands are together it's going to
create
if you have your arms kind of
interlocked doing that same thing
and it creates one petal at the top
in that same thing but in different
direction timing
um you wrap into your arms
and that's just a
wrap tree pedal wrap three pedal
bring full size
also you can do that you know
side
just keep your timing
going
still doing that same thing
there's a touchdown
um
got it also went over outside
and how you can there's two snakes
oh that's cool
and the wrap changes the direction so
Sam going
split Time same direction
you wrap one
let's take it through
or a good example
would be if you stand you're outsides
same opposite
split sand
opposite
that are really that that'll be a good
driller to keep your time
and also with the three wraps
horizontal
or Samsung
snake one and wrap the other
also went over
double biceps
until the bicep wrap
and a good technique for that to help
me to fold your your wrist
over your arms
and that just like lands it perfectly on
your own
you're doing that on the other side
grabbing on the double bicep wrap
to uh go around your elbow
arms close to your armpit as possible
I also went over
wrapping one
while the other one's rotate
so you're changing the direction of one
I went over
these wraps
kind of throws
you can do that same thing with the
double bicep wrap
I also went over contact rolls for
straps
they might
type of timing of Direction gravitate
thing
this contact rule
the bicep wrap as well
so it works right into that stuff
but yeah I think that's everything is is
there anything that you guys remember
uh there was that wall plane one right
that took you
through all the timings and directions
I think it had quarter time in it I'm
not sure yeah totally
that was awesome see pattern I came up
with
it goes through a few different timing
and Direction changes
it's a hard one to explain
it's a
so say you're going into these things
but instead of wrapping them both
one
kind of stop in the middle
I want you in the middle to pull it
apart
so it's like
and then
awesome
that's so cool I really like that one
was that the one where you were doing
like split save raps
you can try to do on the other side
um
the leg versus bicep uh no split same
bicep wraps these these guys huh yeah so
yeah that's right and you're returning
that's yeah so it's with the same arm
bicep drops
with that you can like kind of hug your
arms together
and then whatever way the wraps gonna
rotate off your arm
s
it lands exactly
were you wearing before
you want to practice that with pool
Farms
it's one arm at a time
to wrap
rotate
and then the bottom
just in Hindi
Hot Fire 1998.
oh